[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
you grow slow in your old age circus
yeah
a fate you you'll not share
I've been in your Shadow for hours but
but since nothing
pathetic
laughs
I asked for an equal
and this is what you find
sir
perhaps
a new hunting ground
[Music]
[Applause]
light the fires
the great hunt begins
[Music]
thank you
this is cited in Queens closing in now
cover the door
the Beast could be anywhere
you have no idea
[Music]
Creighton wants to hunt I'll give him
one he'll never forget
he's gonna wish he never came to New
York
satellite scanning all activities
triangulating positions
Target located at Harlem Fish Market all
teams converge the
River
I'm not gonna make it in time
[Music]
miles the hunters tracked Connors to the
Harlem fish market
wizard
I'm on it sounds like Craven's checking
off his we don't have much time move
uh guess we'll chat later
Genki the lizard's loose at the fish
market must be Sushi night you still got
the hunter drone you hijacked and really
tough hiding it for my mom but yeah I'll
I'll boot up and see you there
they got here fast
[Music]
can't let them find colors before he's
done for it
[Music]
thank you
spread out
find the lizard don't engage alone
look at those fish it's been feeding
[Music]
so how's the hunt going watch out guys
scheduled by the three tons of dead fish
not well
where are you Connors
garage might lead to him
Connor's tore through this place
it's out of control
all right
[Music]
where am I now
how'd you find me some of the fish
drones picking up lizards Trail
he's still eating we can catch him off
guard
Yankee get behind me
it's just his skin
doesn't that mean he's getting bigger
hungry or two
hey man new threads the building's
swarming with Hunters any sign of
Connors uh yeah Yankees tracking him hey
Mr Parker
mister
better man what I mean
but the date isn't complete
that wasn't me me neither
I don't even have a stomach so
let's go
go go make him alive
can't lose counters Harry's dying and
he's the only one who can help we won't
you take the Drone I got the jet skis
if I borrow this
but this is really really exciting keep
it tight man watch out for those drones
don't worry they think I'm a friendly
each river is not a river but in fact
the saltwater title flat Spiderman is
fighting on right now
help the tour boat right I've got the
metal murder bird
I warned you about going after Connor's
now this is on you
you clouds that all you got
almost done here civilians are all safe
how you looking
gunship won't quit I'm right behind you
we'll take it down together no time
I got you time to go boom boys no no no
Spider-Man it's good defenses
Spider-Man hang on
over there
[Music]
let's go
it's right behind you I know I know whoa
Steve faster fly faster
yeah
I do not want to be lizard food
thanks
hold on
everyone take cover
what are you guys doing trying to take
out that gunship can't get close enough
but I can't I'm one of them remember bro
that's it hey alley-oop on three hi
one two three Ally
he got away from us
it's good Pete
I saved the tracker
let's go man before he gets too far no
it's mine
sure
it's got big teeth
so do I
um
he's not normally like that right
no
he's never like that
[Applause]